there's the Nobel Prize news and I was
waiting wet it like yesterday evening
nothing then I realized they don't make
the phone call to really close to the
announcement so charged at my phone but
still nothing yeah white it's written on
the whiteboard behind you know they know
Takaaki kajita and Arthur McDonald are
the two people one of them is called
I've forgotten his name but I guess the
first thing to say is there a lot of
physicists out there I don't know them
personally no no no I hadn't hadn't
heard of them and second thing to say is
that actually it's the nature of the
subject that we quite often know what's
going on but we don't necessarily know
who the people are who are associating
with what's going on
so Takaaki kajita you can probably
surmise he's in charge of the
super-kamiokande observed attacked ER in
Japan and Arthur B McDonald who is in
charge of the Sudbury neutrino
Observatory in Sudbury Canada it must be
a very difficult thing to do just
because especially with these big
experimental projects there are many
people involved and it's not like you
know when you've got the Higgs boson you
can point to Higgs but but here the
science behind it had lots of people
involved in it the experiments had lots
of people were involved in it I guess
generally speaking you try and figure
out who was the person who really made
it happen and that's the person you try
and give the prize to my assumption is
that they were both highly influential
if not pioneers in determining each of
their own experiments how they the
layout of the experiment what the
experimental aims would be so though and
then they were in charge of it and they
probably led the the science direction
it was for demonstrating that neutrinos
have mass many of us have heard of
neutrinos that part of the standard
model of particle physics and neutrinos
are these pathetic little particles that
are hardly there at all they're elusive
they only interact via the weak
interaction so they don't have any
charge they don't have any
electromagnetic interactions they don't
have any strong interactions so it means
that every second through so if I take
my thumbnail here and so you can have
you know a million of them passing
through your little finger every second
because the Sun is producing them in
huge numbers and that's the number from
the Sun that are going through your
little finger every second your complete
unaware that they're there and for a
long time these particles were thought
to be massless that went at the speed of
light but more recently there have been
sort of indications that they might have
mass and these really are the
experiments that have demonstrated at
least indirectly that there must be mass
in neutrinos call me by surprise I
wasn't expecting the neutrino
oscillations to win but when they did it
it brought back a very specific memory
in that I actually remember the day that
the super cameo candy results came out
in 1998 I remember it because I was in
Cambridge doing my PhD and it was one of
those days where there was it was just a
buzz
you know people came out in the hallway
and said I'll did you hear and
discovered neutrino oscillations and
people were talking about it and it was
there was so much of a buzz that it was
decided that someone would give a
special seminar just so we could all get
together discuss the results and and
what their significance was so Douglas
golf one of the professor's gave a
seminar on neutrino oscillations and it
just so happens that I actually had the
notes from that seminar because it was
back in the days where I actually took
very comprehensive notes in seminars
because I was very conscientious PhD
student in the standard model we there
there are quarks and there are leptons
and in the leptons there are three
flavors there's the electron the muon
and the Tau and associated with those
three flavors there are neutrinos so
there's the electron neutrino the muon
neutrino and the Tau neutrino and the
bracele got the same properties except
with the electron the muon and the Tau
the masses increase as I go from
electron to muon to tau you would
normally think of a particle that's just
being it you know it it's an electron
once an electron always an electron
maybe it will annihilate and create
photons but you don't think of it as
just switching to something else for
quite a long time they've been a series
of experiments looking at the neutrinos
from the Sun because the nuclear
reactions in the center of the Sun
producing loads and loads of neutrinos
if you try hard enough you ought to be
able to take them down on earth there'd
been this sort of long-running problem
that the detectors on earth weren't
detecting as many neutrinos as they all
do they were detecting about 1/3 as many
as all the theories of what should be
going on in the center of the Sun told
you should be told you should be
and so that either meant that our
understanding of what's going on in the
middle of the Sun is a little bit off or
it means that something's happening to
the neutrinos but we weren't really
quite sure which it could be some fairly
subtle piece of the nuclear fusion
reactions going on in the middle of the
Sun meant that we were kind of messing
things up Ponte Ponte care ponte ponte
car really Bruno Bruno he realized that
actually they could actually begin to
change between themselves so the
electron could maybe turn into a muon on
the muon into an electron or a muon into
a Tau neutrino in a tau neutrino into a
muon neutrino and he developed the
understanding of how this could happen
the key thing that this then meant was
that we had a new way of beginning to
understand why is it that we're not
seeing all these neutrinos from the Sun
as many as we thought there should be
because these are electron neutrinos
from the Sun so if those electron
neutrinos as they propagate to the earth
are converting into something else then
we won't see them as electron neutrinos
on the earth so we'll see a reduced
number what this Sudbury experiment did
is it detected it detected the same
deficit in the electron neutrinos that
all the other experiments are detected
so it showed actually yes those
electrons being produced neutrino
electrons being produced by the Sun
aren't there in the numbers they should
be there in but because it also detected
all the other neutrinos as well it was
able to say but actually they're all
there and it looks like those electron
neutrinos have been converted into the
Muny tree nose and the tau neutrinos so
the total number of neutrinos is right
even though the number of electron
neutrinos is down and that again is a
very strong piece of evidence that
actually you know if the total numbers
right but the ones of one particular
flavor is wrong that means somehow that
particular type of neutrino must have
been turned into the other types of
neutrino this is the notebook that I
used to take notes in seminars in in the
very beginning of my PhD didn't last
very long these are notes from the 18th
of June 1998 on a seminar on neutrino
masses and this was sparked by the
announcement of the detection of
neutrino oscillations by super candy
candy in Japan so I can imagine this was
happening in other universities of the
physics departments around the world
maybe not a formal seminar we happen to
have an expert who could stand up and
talk for an hour on the background
and the implications but when something
like this comes out you know very often
you'll you'll father the person next
door who knows more about it than you do
or maybe gather in a little group and
just just really hash over what it means
that these neutrinos are indeed changing
flavors as they go from one to another
this has a massive knock-on effect must
have been the appropriate word because
now the only way this can happen is that
if that is that the new trainers
themselves have a mass so they are not
moving at the speed of light they've got
a mass they're moving very close to the
speed of light this is if you start
finding out the neutrinos actually has
mass this takes you into this thing that
the particle physics the particle
physicists call physics beyond the
standard model we've now gone beyond the
standard model of particle physics we
have to now begin to understand the
origin of the mass of the neutrinos and
this remains in a something that we're
all trying to get our head around what
water we still don't know the individual
masses of these neutrinos but we know
that they have gotten mass very
occasionally the neutrino will bump into
one of the chlorine atoms in this carbon
tetrachloride this cleaning fluid and
transmute that chlorine atom into an
organ atom and all the particles are
created in this big bill well I imagine
that I wasn't there and so you get a
huge number of electrons and neutrinos